games are so different from other forms
of media that we're used to using in
traditional media magazines and
television would given a story we're
told some ones take on something so with
game we turned that on its head and
instead of starting with the individual
experience we look at the system and how
it kind of produces those experiences
games are good for persuading people to
see the world in a different way so my
question for you is how can video games
become the next persuasive medium for
addressing complex social issues I used
the name persuasive game to describe a
video game that's used to present them
with the situation or an idea that they
hadn't considered if you take freak
piracy as an example which seems like a
kind of strange example but it's been in
the news Somali piracy has generally
been characterized as this kind of an
artistic disruption of global commerce
and we hear those stories in the news
and those are interesting perspectives
but there are our perspectives and if
you ask well what are the pirates really
experiencing or what are they trying to
do is it the same as what we think they
are so Wired magazine did this feature
online as a game about the economics of
piracy and they tried to recast the
subject not as one about politics not as
one about the personalities of conflict
but about the business of piracy itself
the player learns quickly that they must
immediately identify the potential value
of a vessel and then they must work
methodically to produce a modest ransom
piracy becomes more like a business than
like politics seeing the subject of
piracy from the Pirates perspective but
then also from the perspective of like
the balance sheet rather than the
perspective of the captor or a global
trade gives us a new perspective on the
on the issue helps us see something
about it that we wouldn't necessarily
see the from a news story by
experiencing ourselves the vast majority
of big challenges that we face in the
world are systemic challenges the global
economy climate change energy games are
most useful as persuasive tools when
they tackle these these kind of big
problems that are
or interdependent and complicated this
is what I'm after in my games I'm after
discourse more sophisticated complex
conversation about issues persuading
ourselves to be willing to see them as
systems of behavior rather than stories
about individual people